supergirl does PaleyFest when people see  that red cape they expect to see a  certain someone someone they know but  this isn't his story it's mine  ETS old Leon Aguilera moderated the  panel where girl power was a big topic  what has it been like though the whole  girl power phenomenon since then all  right I've had the privilege of meeting  so many young girls and I'm always  excited they are to be there and that is  really moving and I'm always trailer and  cry a little bit I've brought a couple  of my daughters eight and I have a  couple of her friends on this set and  they just rushed to her even without  being introduced and cling to her just  this this iconic you know dream of what  they could be young female fans were  called on to ask questions to the cast  our favorite moment McCobb Brooks  jumping off stage to bring a young super  fan to the spotlight